hey everyone my name is Greg I'm going
to tell you about this paper called epic
fail emulators can tolerate polynomially
many Edge faults for free this paper is
in the upcoming itcs in 2023 and it is
joint work with Mike dinett who's at
Johns Hopkins and with Yasmin nazari
who's at the University of Salzburg okay
so we'll start by telling you what
objects we're going to be talking about
an emulator is defined as in this gray
box at a high level you can think of an
emulator as a tool for sparsifying a
graph getting a much smaller space or
simpler representation of that graph
while approximating its distances so
specifically an emulator of an input
graph g g is an undirected graph but it
can have Edge weights if you like it is
some different graph H with the property
that the distances in the emulator are a
multiplicative K approximation to the
distances in the original graph for
example if this is your input graph G
and here we'll imagine that it's
unweighted or that all of the edges have
weight one if you like this other graph
here is an emulator H and the reason why
it's an emulator H is because if you
look at any two nodes in the input graph
and you look at the corresponding
distance between those two nodes in the
emulator it's at most three times the
distance in the input graph for example
for these top two nodes the original
distance is one and in the emulator it
is three which counts
so emulators are allowed to have edges
that are not present in the original
graph like this long range red Edge
right here
and in principle you could choose any
weight that you wanted for that edge but
in fact this is not a real choice that
you have to make without loss of
generality it is always the right
decision to set the weight of one of
these new emulated edges to be exactly
the distance between its endpoints in
the original graph so here when we are
choosing the weight to attach to this
red Edge we have to choose it to be at
least two the reason is because the
distance between those nodes in the
original graph is two and this lower
inequality in the definition says that
the distances in the emulator need to be
at least as large as the distances in
the original graph and meanwhile there
is no advantage to choosing the edge
weight to be larger than two once we
satisfy this we want our distances in
the emulator to be as small as possible
so we would just choose to set it to V2
so without loss of generality we're
basically just choosing an edge set for
our emulator and then you can think of
the weights as happening automatically
as the distances in the original graph
and as I was saying a second ago the
goal in emulator construction is
generally to get a favorable trade-off
between the size and the stretch so in
other words you would like there to be
as few edges as possible in the emulator
relative to this parameter K which is
measuring the amount of error that you
take on by using the emulator
uh to give an example of the sorts of
theorems that people prove in this space
this is a classic theorem by Alto for
dos Dobkin Joseph and Suarez from 1993.
it says that every endnote graph has a
five emulator on order n to the four
thirds edges and this is best possible
in other words there are some particular
input graphs where if you want a five
emulator you must pay Omega n to the
four thirds edges you can't do any
better
so that's what an emulator is I'm
actually going to talk a little bit
about applications early the
applications are going to play a major
role in pointing us towards the theorem
that we'll be working with and our main
results one common type of application
for emulators is is a pre-processing
step for approximate distance
computation so in other words if you
want to compute shortest path distances
in your input graph and you're okay with
a bit of approximation in that
computation something you might do is
first pass to an emulator which has a
little bit of error in its distances but
it's much sparser and so your algorithms
will run faster on that emulator that
can often be worth it I won't talk too
much about those applications though
what I actually want to talk more about
are these applications in networking
specifically to this thing called
overlay networks so let me tell you what
an overlay network is or at least sort
of a theory cartoon of what overlay
networks are that will motivate what
we're going to talk about
uh so you think of yourself as getting
some kind of Base Network G on input
very often it's the internet that's a
common thing that overlay networks are
applied to but we'll use this little
example in the bottom left and once you
have this base Network your goal is to
carefully design yourself in overlay
Network an overlay network is over the
same vertex set but you can choose any
edges that you want you can choose some
edges from the original base network if
you want you can also choose some
different long range edges like these uh
thick red edges here that are not
corresponding to edges in the original
base network but the difference here to
be clear the base network is an actual
physical Network made of physical nodes
and links and the overlay Network
meanwhile all that is is a pair of node
pairs that's a set of node pairs stored
in memory so face network is a physical
thing the overlay network is just a
purely like logical set of links stored
in memory but the goal of the overlay
network is to basically let yourself
have the illusion that the overlay
network is the original Network you'd
like to be able to like
uh perform routings on this overlay
Network or pass messages along it and
have the routes that you choose in your
overlay Network get seamlessly resolved
into actual physical routes in the base
Network along which information can be
communicated so specifically you might
Define routings on the overlay Network
and what happens is that there's some
very efficient protocol that is
interfacing between the overlay Network
and the base Network that will resolve
the routing you choose into an actual
shortest path in the base Network
specifically it will resolve each Edge
along the path you choose into a
shortest path between those endpoints so
for example if you were to try to route
along this chain of two thick red edges
it would resolve into this dotted red
path where each of the two red edges is
being resolved into a chain of two edges
between its endpoints
okay so that's how overlay networks work
one nice thing about overlay networks is
that you can think of the design of
overlay networks having exactly the same
quality as we were just talking about
emulators having a moment ago you are
choosing the edge set in the overlay
networks and then the weights of all the
edges that you choose get basically
automatically set for you in other words
as soon as you choose this thick red
Edge to appear in your overlay Network
the routing protocol is always going to
resolve it into a chain of two edges and
so it's kind of like the weight of this
Edge automatically becomes two and
there's nothing you can do about it just
gets set to the distance in the
underlying graph
so that's one point of similarity the
other point of similarity is that you
often have the same goals in designing
an emulator as you do in designing an
overlay Network specifically uh you
generally want your overlay networks to
be sparse or simple so that there's an
advantage to working with these instead
of directly with the base Network and
additionally you want the distances in
your overlay Network to be not too much
larger than the distances in the
original Network in other words if
there's like two adjacent nodes that can
talk to each other very quickly in the
base Network it would be kind of bad if
then the shortest path between those
nodes in the overlay network was a
million times as long you'd be
introducing a lot of latency between
those nodes and that would be too big of
a penalty to make using the overlay
network worth it so together these two
goals are exactly like saying that this
automatically weighted overlay network
is a sparse K emulator of the input
graph
okay so that's the tie between overlay
networks and emulators and we're going
to run with it uh one thing about
networking applications is that Parts
can fail it's very common for nodes or
edges to go down temporarily and need
repair and everything else still has to
run smoothly around them this introduces
this additional constraint in
applications which is that an emulator
can be unusable if these failures could
completely destroy its stretch
properties let me give you an example to
say what I mean here's our input graph
and emulator from before and we'll look
at this specific pair of nodes UV
originally the distance is one in the
emulator the distance is three which is
totally acceptable a three emulator is
fine you're willing to take on times
three error however let's now imagine
that this node fails this node named F
goes down temporarily
so now the distance between u and v in
the original graph is still one but the
distance between u and v and the
emulator is now Infinity because as long
as this node has failed it's just
disconnected so suddenly if you need to
be concerned about these failures you
really regret using the emulator because
these two nodes that used to be able to
talk to each other now can't talk to
each other at all and that's not worth
it
so this motivates and I'll make this
formula in a moment but this is
motivating a different uh type of
definition that we could work with that
would be an emulator that has good
stretch properties and which still has
good stretch properties after these
failures so for now I'm just going to
sort of vaguely say this three emulator
H that we came up with it is not a one
vertex fault tolerant three emulator of
the input graph G and the reason is
because there exists at least one vertex
that could fail in such a way that the
remaining part of the emulator is not a
three emulator of the remaining part of
the input graph
okay so that's good uh there we now sort
of see what could generally go wrong let
me work towards making this definition
more formal so that I can tell you
results about it this basic model of
thought tolerant emulators was
introduced by the same set of authors me
Mike and Yasmin at itcs last year and
it's directly motivated by this overlay
Network application but here's the idea
so base Network edges can fail those are
the ones that correspond to physical
links that could go down
these failures don't affect the edge
side of the overlay network no matter
what remember the edge set of the
overlay network is just a set of node
pairs stored in memory and that can't
break even if a physical Edge breaks
that node pair is still sitting there in
memory but what does happen when these
base Network edges fail is that this
protocol that resolves overlay Network
edges into shortest paths in the
underlying graph that protocol needs to
get updated in light of the failures and
that can change the weights of the edges
in the overlay Network so really what
the effect of edge failures is is it is
not a change in the emulator Edge set
but it is a change in the emulator Edge
weights so this set of three graphs here
on in the middle is an example of what
I'm talking about and this original
graph on the left this thick red
emulator Edge would have weight too
since that's the distance in the
underlying graph between these endpoints
under the two Edge failures that are
marked in the middle the effect that
would have is that it would cause the
weight of this Edge to update to become
three since after the failures that's
the new shortest path that the edge will
get resolved to in the overlay Network
resolution protocol
and similarly if these two edges instead
were to fail then the weights of this
emulator Edge would get updated to four
okay
so with that in mind here is exactly the
same information as on the previous
slide but now it's a fully formal
definition so this is the definition we
use we just say that an F Edge fault
tolerant K emulator it is a graph H
which is the emulator so that for any
set of failing edges if you were to
compare the distances in the failed
version of the input graph that's G
minus F here
and you compare those distances to the
distances in the emulator under the
weight updating Associated to those
failing edges then you get a k
approximation
so another more informal way of saying
what's going on in this definition is
that for any set of failing edges F that
we might need to consider so size at
most f
the overlay Network distances are still
a times K approximation to the distances
in the failed version of the base
Network G minus F okay so that's the
definition of emulators with failures I
want to make a quick note that if you
are familiar more with the algorithmic
applications of emulators than the
networking applications of emulators you
might be objecting to this definition it
might feel wrong to have this like
automatic weight updating behavior and I
would totally understand that we are not
really claiming at all that this is a
reasonable definition of fault tolerance
for the algorithmic applications of
emulators we are really only claiming
applications in the networking sense so
I just want to sort of quickly say this
definition is I think of it as being a
networking only sort of thing
okay so anyways uh with that set up in
mind here is the results that uh the
same set of us three authors proved last
year we were specifically studying
vertex failures and we proved that every
graph has an F fault tolerance F vertex
fault tolerant five emulator with this
many edges and I've separated this out
into two parts this purple end of the
four thirds I'm going to call that the
base cost it's the base cost because
Omega n to the four over three edges are
needed for even a non-fault tolerant
five emulator that is known to be tight
so we're gonna have to pay that end to
the four thirds no matter what the more
interesting thing to look at is what is
the price of fault tolerance so that's
this o tilde F to the one over three
term right here that o tilde is hiding
log n factors but what it means is that
like really the price of this vertex
fault tolerance for emulators it's this
you want F vertex fault tolerance you
pay a factor of f to the one over three
so this turns out to be tight um up to
these hidden log factors you can't do
any better but anyways uh Edge failures
are what we are looking at now in this
current paper that I'm talking about and
for exactly the same reason you're gonna
have to pay this end to the four over
three term the only question is what is
the price of fault tolerance that we're
going to need to associate here is it
going to be more than this F to the one
over three is it going to be the same is
it going to be less it's not really
clear and that's the question to invest
investigate and it turns out that the
answer is this the answer is that the
price of fault tolerance for f Edge
fault tolerance in emulators it is
constant and this is really surprising
we are saying that it is a constant
independent of both n and F with the
only extra condition Dimension being
this is f needs to be at most this
moderate polynomial
so specifically the biggest cost is n to
the four thirds the price of fault
tolerance as long as f is not too large
is free here so now we can go back to
this subtitle of this paper which is
emulators can tolerate polynomial
polynomially many Edge faults for free
and point to what it means pointing at
the fact that like the extra factor that
you pay is actually independent of f is
just a constant
okay so I think this is kind of
surprising uh let me state it in a
different way so the main result for
five emulators is that for any endnode
graph and parameter uh F which can be up
to n to the two over nine there is an F
Edge fault tolerant five emulator on N
to the four thirds edges and you can do
no better than this even for non-fault
tolerant emulators meanwhile a natural
question that you might have is how much
bigger can this F be could we take this
range n to the two over nine and push it
up a little bit higher the answer is
maybe all that we are able to prove in
this paper is that you're not able to
push F Beyond n to the one over three if
f is larger than that false tolerance is
definitely not for you anymore but there
is a gap here in closing that Gap is one
of the open questions that we're leaving
I'll say a little bit more about that at
the end
okay so let me give you a couple of
proof ideas uh this picture is a router
on fire which I don't know I'm a
theorist but I assume that something
like this is what's happening when you
need fault tolerance
uh anyways so in order to say the proof
ideas let me quickly try to say what is
the proof idea in the non-fault
tolerance setting so this original
result by Alto for dos Dobkin Joseph and
Suarez from 1993 where they said every
endnote graph has a non-fault tolerant
five emulator on N to the four over
three edges let me say quickly how that
works so their proof strategy is to very
carefully construct their emulator so
that it has girth greater than six as a
reminder the girth of the graph is the
smallest number of edges in any cycle so
this is the same as saying that it has
no three four five or six Cycles in it
and after they do that they use this
Lemma from extremely combinatorics that
says that any endnode graph of girth
greater than 6 can have at most n to the
four over three edges so that constrains
the size of their emulator
the way that they did this the way that
they uh constructed age to have high
girth is was with this really simple and
really clever greedy construction
algorithm so specifically I'm going to
show you a picture of this in just a
second but they start with h being the
empty emulator it's on the same vertex
set as the input graph but with no edges
at all
and then they are considering the edges
of the input graph in order of
increasing weight and they add the edge
to the emulator if it's currently
necessary and what we mean by if it's
currently necessary is if the distance
between the endpoints in the of the edge
is more than five times the weight of
the edge in other words this node pair
UV that are the endpoints of the edge
currently violates the emulator
inequality that it needs to satisfy and
so therefore we better add the edge to
fix that so here's a quick picture
imagine this is your input graph g h
which we are going to design to be a
five emulator starts out with no edges
but over the same vertex set we consider
the edges one at a time when we consider
this the distance in the input graph is
one the distance in the emulator is
infinity currently since they're
disconnected so we would take that edge
into the emulator then we consider the
next one take it by the same logic
consider the next one take it consider
the next one take it finally we consider
this last edge here we notice that the
distance between these nodes in the
original graph is one and the distance
between these nodes and the emulator is
three there's this path of three edges
that we already added and so therefore
we already have better than a five
approximation between u and v and the
emulator and this Edge UV is not
currently necessary in the emulator so
we would instead reject it from the
emulator at this point
so this is specifically the five
emulator that would be built I'll say
two things about it one is that you
might notice this is actually doing
something more specific than producing
an emulator it's producing a spanner
which is a special type of emulator that
is a sub graph of the input graph the
other thing is that you can notice that
this floor cycle in the input graph
didn't get closed in the emulator we
rejected its last Edge and if you want
to see why this results in emulators of
height girth you can kind of convince
yourself through similar logic that it
will never close a cycle of length three
four five or six so therefore its girth
will be greater than six
okay so that's the basic idea uh to very
quickly say what we are doing one of the
most surprising things I think is that
we are actually using a similar greedy
construction algorithm in order to build
our fault tolerant emulators so right
off the bat I'll talk more about this
algorithm in a moment but we are going
to produce emulators that are a subgraph
of the input graph so another way to say
that that might feel very strange if
you're familiar with this area that like
we are claiming an advantage to using
emulators and yet the emulators that we
build are subgraphs of the input graph
you know in a way what we mean by that
we talk more about this in the paper but
what we mean by that is that uh the
power that we are gaining is from the
model of fault tolerance changing in the
world of emulators more so than the
freedom to add a long-range emulator
edges in our Construction
but anyways uh the algorithm that we're
using is basically the same as the one
before we start with h being the empty
emulator we consider the edges of the
input graph one by one and we add it to
H if it's currently necessary
the only thing that's really changing is
the meaning of if currently necessary
before if currently necessary was just
if the emulator inequality was violated
over the endpoints of this Edge UV here
uh we need to say like it's violated if
there exists any fault set F that is a
valid fault set it's not too large in
such a way that the emulator inequality
is violated in the re-weighted version
of the emulator this is a bit more of a
technical thing to chew on here but you
can just think of it as saying like if
you can prove given the current state of
the emulator that it's safe to throw
away the edge then go ahead and throw
away the edge if you can't prove that
you'd better take the edge into your
emulator to be safe
so at a very high level the way that our
analysis works and things get technical
very fast I'm not going to say much
about it here we're using the blocking
set method which is a strategy that's
been used in the last few papers in this
area but it formalizes the following
intuition
a moment ago we were talking about a
similar greedy algorithm and we showed
that it has growth greater than six this
is different and so it is not still true
that the emulator we produce is going to
have growth greater than six but just in
a very fuzzy intuitive level because we
are using such a similar algorithm it
might feel like the emulator that we
produce should be close to girth greater
than six whatever that means like it it
is structurally similar in some key way
to a high growth graph
and after that it might also be
intuitive to say any graph that is close
to having birth greater than six again
whatever that means should have close to
order n to the four over three edges so
my hope is that these two bullet points
make sense that this fuzzy intuitive
level the way that you formalize these
two bullet points is using an object
called blocking sets it's kind of like
saying your graph can have cycles of
length six or less but they admit in an
unusually small hitting set or something
like that the actual definition is much
more technical so I'll refer to the
paper there but this is the intuition
behind what we're doing
okay anyways uh here's another picture
of something that presumably might go
wrong that might cause you to need a
fault tolerant emulator uh but I'll just
sort of say our generalizations and wrap
up the talk here so here is the um we
were sort of focusing on five emulators
just to have a simple example to keep in
mind through this talk here's the more
General non-edge fault tolerant theorem
that was proved by Alto for dos Dobkin
Joseph and Suarez in 1993. it says for
any positive integer okay every end node
graph has a 2K minus one error emulator
on N to the one plus one over K edges
and moreover this is best possible if
you're willing to assume this thing
called the girth conjecture Which is
popular in the area
anyways we're our main result for odd K
is a positive result we are able to
prove that for any odd k a similar
phenomenon to what I was just talking
about uh for the case of five emulators
which corresponds to k equals three does
in fact hold so for five emulators we
got free fault tolerance up to F to the
two over nine for any odd K you can have
free Edge fault tolerance for 2K minus 1
emulators up to some polynomial so this
is good we get polynomial amounts of
free fault tolerance for all odd K
interestingly something very different
is happening for even k for k equals two
so in other words emulators of stretch
three since you're plugging two into
this 2K minus 1 term here
we can completely refute the possibility
of free fault tolerance we proved this
is a lower bound this like you need F to
the one-half times n to the three halves
edges and that suggests that if f is a
moderate polynomial moderate polynomial
or any polynomial at all I mean you're
already paying more than what is
Promised in the non-fault tolerant case
so this phenomenon that exists for odd K
it definitely doesn't exist for k equals
two
and for even uh that should be even K
strictly greater than two like so four
six eight and so on it is an open
question whether or not there is free
Edge fault tolerance at all we were not
able to resolve it the only thing we can
say is that if the number of faults is
uh strictly like asymptotically larger
than n to the one over K there's no free
fault tolerance but below that it may or
may not exist and we're leaving that as
an open question that I think is really
interesting
okay uh so I just mentioned some open
questions here they all are on one slide
this is one that I mentioned earlier uh
one thing that I think would be a good
follow-up use of time that I'm
interested in seeing resolved is to
settle the range of free Edge fault
tolerance for five emulators we are able
to prove that if you have n to the two
over nine
false it's free you only you don't have
to pay anything extra and if you were to
have asymptotically more than n to the
one over three false it is not free then
you would have to pay something Above
This n to the four thirds term
uh and closing that Gap or figuring out
what is this value of this constant C
sub 3 that determines the threshold of
free fault tolerance it's a very
interesting open question
another open question is to improve the
range of free fault tolerance for 2K
minus 1 emulators when K is odd in
general the range of free fault
tolerance that we get for some choice of
odd K it falls in this range it is Omega
1 over K squared and it is at most one
over K but we don't know what the right
value of the constant is
within this so we're trying to improve
our understanding of when fault
tolerance is free for emulators when K
is odd is an interesting open question
and probably the hardest but also most
interesting open question of all is this
one is there any free Edge fault
tolerance for 2K minus 1 emulators when
K greater than 4 is an even number can
we get a similar phenomenon to what was
going on with the odd case for the even
case except for k equals 2 where we know
it's definitely not going to work
okay so these are open uh I would love
to talk with anyone about these who is
interested here's just a quick wrap up
uh the model of edge fault tolerant
emulators that we are working with it
has applications in networking but not
really in algorithms this is really
focusing on the overlay Network
application in order to be justified
uh the main result which I think is very
surprising is that you can get
resilience to polynomially many Edge
failures while still only paying a
constant factor in your emulator size
for that power which is much much
stronger than anything else that has
shown up in similar questions in this
area
uh the last thing is just that the exact
amount of free fault tolerance is still
very open those last three open
questions that I mentioned are all about
pinning this down so thank you for your
attention and here's one last thing that
I suppose could go wrong with the
computer uh that would cause you to want
to read our paper so I hope you do I'm
happy to talk with you about it and if
anyone's at itcs I'm looking forward to
seeing you there thanks everybody